Ron DeSantis now leads Donald Trump in
the 2024 betting markets now as I as I
always do because I don't want any
confusion on this these are not polls
these are people betting who do you
believe will be the Republican
Presidential nominee and although the
numbers themselves have fluctuated the
money is behind DeSantis and Trump
almost exclusively the next person down
is Nikki Haley and she's almost nowhere
she's she's in the toilet right to use
the language that these folks use and it
has been a head-to-head between Trump
and DeSantis Trump leading that for much
of the last year but it is now for many
days straight and every day since the
2022 midterm has been DeSantis DeSantis
DeSantis now I don't believe for a
second that this proves DeSantis will be
the nominee and in fact one of the
things I think
is important to think realistically
about is do we really believe that in a
national campaign
if it's the Trump of 2016's Republican
primary with the insults and the
aggressiveness and the attacks and the
ridiculing of the other candidates do we
really think that in a national race
DeSantis can actually stand up to the
bully Trump DeSantis to me although he's
a horrible person
wrong on most issues
completely disagree with him politically
all these different things I don't
actually know that DeSantis can get down
in the mud
uh down in the toilet water with Trump
the way you probably need to in order to
actually defeat Donald Trump in a far in
a hard-fought uh uh primary I don't know
the answer yet one way or the other so
the importance and the interest in
looking at these betting numbers relates
to the things we're going to look at
next on the show which include other
prominent Republicans turning on Trump
media Outlets turning on Trump this
election and the disaster of Trump's
failed critical contested endorsements
and we'll give you the list again later
many of you know the list already it has
opened the door for many Republicans and
media Outlets to just say this is my
opportunity to turn on Donald Trump so
the numbers right now in polling we
actually don't have new 2024 Republican
nominee polling since the election we'll
have it maybe tomorrow or Wednesday and
it'll be interesting to look at in the
betting markets
in the betting markets the favor has
turned towards Ron DeSantis over Donald
Trump and that informs what we are going
to talk about next